[Music]
hello everyone hello
lionel hello everyone and
hello jean françois welcome to talk to
you about the cloud in a series of five
videos of about 5 to 7 minutes
we will present the bricks
used to develop a
internet of things project or internet of
things my name is jean françois mas
crazy i am a consultant claude in
the professional services
organization entity of google cloud
for my part i work within
the partners entity and my job is
to  helping integrators and software publishers on a daily basis
to make the
best possible use of google cloud platform
so from the month of a wing can you
explain to me what an
internet of things project is altogether but
we're going  take an example to our customers
use the tools to help
drivers on a daily basis they use
they have in fact created an object which will
be placed in the car and which will
take in real time the state of the
battery which will in fact make it possible to
notify the driver at 2 of the fact that he
must change this battery before
it breaks down practical and
turns out to be easy said like that but I have
heard of a service that is
'call aliotti body yes absolutely
I like presented to tools body
like like plumbing it does not
really offer visible functionalities but
on the other hand it sets up all
the infrastructure which will allow you
a secure and scalable way of
manage your haiti project with your
hands dirty
yes with pleasure so we will start
by generating a key and this key will
allow to authenticate the object
both on the object and on haiti body and
from this moment  there in fact the object
will be able to post messages in
antibodies you see if the aliotti
body console for the demo we will use
a raspberry pi to simulate a
haiti device at first I will
generate a loss of keys this pair of
c  lés will allow me to identify each
device once the loss of keys is generated
we will install it on the device
finally we will register this
device on the haiti body platform
once these operations are done the device is
ready to publish messages
we will  for example publish a hello
world the system is auto scalable
which means that the google teams will
manage the increase in load and its
problems and the system will
adapt automatically and on
the side the payment is made to the user which
avoids  having provisioned all these
machines so how do we secure all
that i.e. what do we need to
secure and how is it there in fact
all the records of the key is
really crucial
the idea is that  each key will be
unique for each device and suddenly
aliotti corps will in fact be able to
determine if an object has the right or not
to push a message according to that
and if it does not have the right we will go straight
continued  destroy the message
automatically okay then 1.6 g 1
million objects I'm still not going
to register a parent no indeed
so the idea is to use the sdk 1
of haiti corps and therefore  to automate all
that so we're going to degenerate into millions of
keys and then we're going to create a
script that will push its keys in and
to tic gold to register the divas
so now I'm coming into production
how do I supervise the
platform  good question
there you are going to use another tool of the
clotte platform which is called stack
driver and the idea for example is
to analyze the flow of messages
1 typically if you have not received a
message for five or ten minutes
c  is that there is probably a problem
so suddenly the idea is to generate an
alert 1 so that an operator can
take the necessary actions to
repair the situation to that of me
so to close this first episode and
like us  will do it for the
next four I want you  s invites you to take a
look at the comments of the videos
you will find resources there to
deepen everything that lionel explained to us
today if you have followed
so far thank you and we
say see you soon see
you soon
[Music  ]